okay here we are on overtime
these are the questions people send in
uh this one is for you governor governor
it's rumored you're considering another
presidential run in 2024 is there any
truth to that sure
oh I love that
very I'm telling you this Show's rubbing
off on him he's getting very loose yes
yeah that was me I never had the
reputation of being bold
we're all flower type so you are
considering it sure yeah yeah you should
I mean why not because we need a normal
Republican I mean a As Good As It Gets
Republican
you know
you know you never had kids you're such
a sweet talker
I mean but really I mean but do you
think you could really take the party
away from the clutches of the Trump cult
as it is now and because even if it's
not Trump it's going to be a Trumper
I would like to see what happens in the
midterms I think you know all I heard in
2016 was that we're going to do so much
winning that we're going to be tired of
winning and he's going to we're going to
ask him not to win anymore and then we
lost the house of the senate in 18 we
lost the presidency in 20. we lost two
Senate seats in Georgia in 20. it's a
lot of losing I think they might want to
go back to winning again okay uh caddy
as a Brit what's your perspective of the
UK's parliamentary system compared to
our mode of governments oh well academic
question for you but um it's irrelevant
because most of most democracies are not
what we have I mean they have at least
managed to get rid of leaders they
didn't like yeah it's a lot easier you
know they took on Boris Johnson they
felt that Boris Johnson wasn't good for
the party and he was out the next day
right
um which certainly doesn't happen here
with the Republican party and Donald
Trump despite all the losing that might
have happened no and they seem to have
elections and I think the other thing
you know I was over in the UK for the
Queen's funeral and I'm not particularly
a royalist or a republican but I don't
have particularly strong feelings either
way but it has made me think being here
there's something to be said for
separating your head of state and your
elected officials and not investing in
the presidency all of the kind of
ceremonial stuff that goes with having a
head of state you give your PR you give
your elected head of state prime
minister a grilling you make sure
they're held to account and then you
have your queen or your king
handle the gossip
not really I I I I'm it's relevant
because the other day I had this
Kardashian on my podcast hasn't dropped
yet but and I was saying that the
Kardashians kind of became like the
royal family of America they're not
governing of course oh my God
[Laughter]
you just need people need some family
that they can follow and and sort of
like project themselves onto or follow
their gossip or their craziness and how
about Fred Barney you just put them up
there
be helpful Chris Wallace your new show
explores a wide range of Interest
unrelated to politics like this what
triggered this shift for you do you did
you become burned out from politics
after the past six years of trump
Madness I didn't become burned out but I
became a bit bored and I will actually
say not in the Trump years because as
much of a show as it was uh it was
always interesting and you'd wake up on
Sunday and we had somebody was literally
in charge of the tweets because when I
got in at six in the morning between
then and nine when I would do the show
things would change would depending on a
trump tweet but I spent so much time for
instance in 2021
each week the slicing the salami thinner
and thinner about what was the marginal
difference between the build back better
plan this week versus last week and it
became kind of a bore and conversely
good politics should be a boar no really
that's it's not it's not supposed to be
a show well supposed to deal with big
issues
and that's boring the way by that's why
Biden's good he's doing it what's why we
elected him let's get back to boring and
normal yes that's that's I mean
you're right the uh covering it build
back better was boring because they but
you know they started with this number
and then guys objected and mentioned in
this and Cinema and everything and then
it came down to a better number and a
better program and they passed it that's
the way it's supposed to work boring and
effective and you know people's lives
are better for it no no but let me just
say what was the host of the Sunday talk
show boring is not good but the other
thing was I'm interested in a lot of
stuff I mean I look at the people you
have on the show right and they're not
all politicians all right no and you
know with their scripture talking points
he has always he has always been one of
the least boring politicians in America
right on this program right okay okay
um I guess
so did you vote for Trump
hi you know there's a secret ballot
some people don't care about the
question yeah it was worth a try was it
yeah I mean why not I'll have a better
question did you vote for Trump that's
it both times yep wow wow
and you would again no
good try
you've got more honesty out of me than
you've gotten anybody else
oh uh I'll take my winnings and go home
uh okay this is for everybody Biden is
declaring the risk of nuclear Armageddon
is at the highest level since the Cuban
Missile Crisis have a great weekend
everybody
[Applause]
as Russia continues to discuss the use
of nukes on Ukraine what is the US's
best course of action prevent such Dire
Straits well I'll start off I hate to
keep saying this but I'm glad Biden's
here for this and not some idiot or
someone who's 39. if we're talking about
the worst nuclear possible crisis since
the Cuban Missile Crisis yeah I want the
79 year old guy there who's seen it all
yeah I don't yeah I'm not sure the use
of the word Armageddon is very helpful I
mean
Putin wants us to be afraid and you can
I mean half of Europe's in uproar about
him saying Armageddon because actually
all that does is play into Putin's
desire to make us afraid you can say
there's a serious threat and there is a
serious threat and Bill Burns the
director of the CIA who thank goodness
used to be the ambassador to Moscow has
made it very clear to the Russians that
were they to launch any kind of tactical
or
small nuclear weapon as if that was
possible he need tiny teeny tiny yeah
the the Americans would bomb every
Russian column in Ukraine and the war
would be over and sink every ship in the
Black Sea that's great I just not sure
they use the word Armageddon and then
what happens and then and then he's then
you've you've doubled down on the guy
who doesn't want to lose the war but has
nuclear weapons well but why is but
perhaps even worse than that if he goes
away who replaces him and then you've
got a whole bunch of nukes laying out
there unsupervised the second most in
the in the world and you got to start
thinking about how you deal with that
and on your point about you want someone
who's seen it all so do I but I'd like
to also understand it and when he says
nuclear Armageddon it's clear to me
doesn't understand it because he's
causing alarm in in a way that is not
productive like you know what if you
really think that then go and try to
start to fix it but don't give us some
pronouncement scare the crap out of
everybody well everyone should have the
crap scared out of them and there's no
way to there's no way to fix it I don't
know if there's any way to fix it we
could have fixed it in 1987 when
Gorbachev and Reagan came that close
to getting to zero that would have been
a terrible idea a terrible idea I think
so
nuclear weapons yes because there would
never be zero nuclear weapons and in a
world where there's zero nuclear weapons
the person with one nuclear weapon is
King wins yep that's right may be right
but it's but we did we don't need I mean
how many do we have now at the time we
had like 30 000 each which is look the
pro to me the problem with him saying
this stuff is your job is not to be a
weatherman when you're president oh let
me let me show you what the map looks
like we're abundant right
it's to go and come with a solution and
to say oh yeah we're close to nuclear
armagedness we've been since 1962. okay
thanks a lot now genius what are you
going to do about it well what would you
do about it what is the solution okay so
we're in an alternate universe now Chris
Christie is President he doesn't use
this terminology but he has the solution
well first
all ears
I'm so so glad to have your attention
what what he should be doing is he
should be playing a constructive role
between zelinski and Putin Putin knows
he's losing Putin's not stupid he knows
he's losing you got to give an exit ramp
he's got to find a way to get out
without when Saving Face okay but that's
a non-starter because it Rhymes he's got
you know he's flush with cash from the
high oil price he's about to bring on
another 300 000 troops he controls the
state media he can call this a winner
any moment that he wants to call it a
win so he is choosing not to take the
exit round I don't think there's any
negotiation especially now to be done
between zelenski and Putin particularly
yeah I disagree well zelensk the exit
ramp would be some accommodation where
he gets some territory in Ukraine and
zelenski isn't going to go for that
they'll go for letting them keep crime
in
well that's kind of a done deal that was
annexable well but that's some territory
in Ukraine I've got to go in there and
try to sell it man don't be like setting
your hair on fire and yelling uh about
new program again on the other hand
you're blaming Biden for Putin's what
Putin is doing
buying for saying nuclear arm again but
well yes but you can't blame him for the
failure of of Putin to take off ramp
after off ramp that has been locked to
him I just don't you're saying well no
you got to go in and sell it no going to
make them Putin doesn't want an off-ramp
at this point and there's nothing you
can do about it and frankly I think
Biden has handled I agree I think
Armageddon was a stupid remark but
you've got to handle this as well as you
can and right now
bloodying his nose and pushing back in
that's what they are for the Ukraine
pretty good strategy yeah Biden's done a
good job on this he has uh he's he's
rallied NATO he's kept from his sister
yes he's supplied the Europeans with
extra gas to try and get him through the
winter as much as he can he's yeah he's
can he kind of thought Ukraine could win
when nobody else did you know he said
we'll just we'll just back and I don't
and I don't disagree with any of that
but I think that the alarmist language
he's using yeah creates an atmosphere
that makes it more likely to happen not
less I agree well we will be back next
week hopefully thank you very much
foreign